Tessa know Nikki's parking violators
don't have to worry about being ticketed
these days even in pedestrian zones
that's because officers like Janna swagg
tatis aren't issuing them anymore
Baghdatis was a traffic warden for the
local authority but his department was
shut down to save money what he's got
the ball after I used to combat this
kind of thing he's got that now I
couldn't care less after all and I can't
do anything anyway is that with the
troika and the government want they get
it doesn't make sense we keep things
tidy got our better the house the police
are supposed to take over traffic warden
duties at some stage and moped fan yeah
no spectators will get 500 euros a month
paid till next May and that's all his
Union gives him some moral support
telling him things aren't all that bad
with the job cuts just a guy kinabalu
from what we've heard only 4,000 out of
a supposed 12 and a half thousand civil
servants will actually become unemployed
the other eight and a half thousand will
be given jobs in other departments it's
important to remember that they need
people to compensate for those who are
retiring for instance so cool that
slender hope is all Baghdatis has
because he's too young for retirement
and too old for the private sector at
the Town Hall the 56 year-old applies
for a vacant civil service slot actually
enough to bring upon opening the but
there's not much chance for anyone over
50 here especially since we don't have
the same up-to-date knowledge the
younger ones have with that they've
generally got university degrees I guess
I've got a five percent chance baghdatis
has long spent his savings and his
income has to support his son and his
wife who have also been unemployed for
years like most Greek families the only
thing left is their apartment i would
estimate that selling the apartment
isn't a solution
my attention will be 500 euros a month
how can I rent an apartment on that and
still pay for electricity and things
then I'd have nothing left to eat enough
all by the news but it's another two
years before Yanis worked out as can
retire and he's got no plan B